alan johnson um
javid is going to be making his first
appearance as hell secretary in the next
hour or so
um what do you think he should be the
first thing he does
as he sits down at his desk get a proper
briefing
um about what's going on he has got the
luxury of being appointed at the weekend
so sometimes health secretaries and
other cabinet ministers are appointed in
you know at lunch time and then at two
o'clock have to go onto the floor of the
house of commons and stand at the
dispatch box
and act as if they are all knowing about
every issue in their department
sanji's got at least got a few days i
think he's a good appointment by the way
i think you know in a cabinet of
sycophants which has been one of the
problems
he stands out because he refused to
accept the outrageous demands
placed upon him by the prime minister
and dominic cummings and
you know gave up his job as chancellor
um on an issue of principle and i think
that stands him in good
stead he's got a huge uh i mean it's not
just the virus by the way the nhs is
going to go through a
huge change uh a beneficial change
because they're going to reverse
all the lansley reforms this is part of
the nhs plan that the government
thankfully have accepted
and go back from a system where they
were
you almost had to have a competition
lawyer in the corner every time one
hospital
talked to each to another they were
going to go towards they're going to go
towards cooperation and integration and
that's a very big and very beneficial
change and it has to be put through
uh in legislation over the coming year
you you mentioned dominic cummings and
um i'm afraid i just can't resist
um asking this uh do you have any
sympathy for
how mr cummings might feel this morning
having
in a way got rid of that his nemesis he
said
uh hancock should have been sacked 15
times last year and so on
uh and no doubt have been cheering when
hancock
went and then to find his been replaced
by the bloke
that walked rather than take cummings's
orders
it must be um a bit disappointing for
him
i have absolutely no sympathy for
dominic cummings at all and neither
would he require
but you know what he said about matt
hancock's failings
are all there in a wonderful book called
failures of state
by the two sunday times insight
journalist it was published back in
march
and strangely enough although it
contains every dot and comma
and much more of the disaster that was
this thing that hancock did i mean
hancock
took 15 000 people out of
uh hospitals and put them into adult
social care so he took the most
vulnerable
to this disease and placed them in the
area where they were most likely
to get it it had terrible terrible
consequences
hancock's point was that he told the
prime minister that it had all been
uh done safely or whatever it was but
but read the book failures of state it
shows how there were absolutely no
safeguards all the regulations were
suspended
for this mass migration of elderly
people
out of hospitals and into adult social
care it was a disaster and one of
many disasters in those early days that
hopefully will come out
in the um in the inquiry when it's
eventually held
we're hearing about um further let's
call them failures of state
uh this morning we are hearing about
personal email accounts being used when
perhaps they should not and we are
hearing
about the inquiry which uh brandon lewis
told this program
will be mounted into how those pictures
of mr hancock uh and
his um aid were
found and of course we've now just had
news
that sensitive defense documents
were found at a bus stop in kent
um home secretary health secretary
this must be the sort of nightmare that
that you you wake up sweating about
you might remember trevor because like
me you go back a long way
alistair darling getting castigated over
some nhs records that went
missing back in 2009 i think it was and
they were
treasury documents um and i hope the
same kind of castigation is going to
fall upon this government
on the first issue i could never
understand why there was a camera in the
secretary of state's office
there was never a camera in my office
when i was health secretary or in any of
the other
uh five cabinet positions uh i i think
i think the rule is um that secretary
cabinet
members are not to be monitored by
anybody including
security services without express
permission of the prime minister
exactly yeah it goes back to harold
wilson's uh time
although of course our telephone
conversations there's always someone
listening in as a member of your private
office
to get a record so that you've got some
justification and some backup for
what's talked about so this private um
telephone account of matt hancocks
uh through which apparently he
negotiated some of these extremely
questionable deals for his mates to get
large lumps of taxpayers money
that that's uh that's certainly worthy
uh of the investigation so there are
problems here that need to be
looked at and go beyond matt hancock but
as for matt i mean i can't you might
have covered this trevor
you i thought when this neil ferguson
issue arose
matt hancock didn't have to pile in on
neil ferguson he chose to pile in
and say that neil remember neil ferguson
had a visit from his
friend that it was extraordinary
behavior
and that everyone had to obey the rules
and even went so
far although the police had declared
they were not going to take any action
for this breach of law matt hancock said
if they do take action i will support
them
i mean it's talk about you know a
justified comeback
uh when you do that to someone a sage
advisor you know it wasn't even a
cabinet colleague someone who couldn't
really answer back
you deserve everything you get uh alan
johnson um
let's take it away from the person for
the moment
um what is emerging about the
culture of this department department of
health
contracts allegedly granted to cronies
we don't know
to what extent matt hancock was involved
in any of that but
the story is being told is that there's
cronyism
that there's a chamocracy that uh
email accounts are being used to keep
information away from
officials now you were there i think for
a year
a bit more than a year two years three
that meant that long
okay did you get any sense
of that being the sort of underlying
culture in this department
no and i think i think you can't divorce
it from individuals i think this is a
a boris johnson style government maybe
cummings was in there as well
all this well let's wave all the rules
you know bonfire of the rules and do
what we want to do
when we want to do it i was also there
through a pandemic of course
uh it wasn't as extensive as this one
but we thought it was going to be
the return of h1n1 spanish flu that
killed
billions of people bit literally
billions back in uh
1918. it had come back and we thought it
was the big one so i saw how the nhs
operated
um and i had real admiration there's you
know
the chief medical officer working with
the nhs working with the department
it's it's a it's a tricky organization
to run but there was nothing about that
organization that suggested
cronyism or or anything else until
the kind of government cronyism came in
um just very briefly alan johnson um
how will you judge sajid javid or what
will be
the key performance indicators uh
on which you would judge him leaving
party politics aside
on whether he has been a good health
secretary or not
well i've left party politics aside to
welcome him i think he's a good
appointment
um i think he's the best possible
appointment
other than perhaps uh jonathan ashworth
under a labour government but
i think sergey getting on with his job
quietly undemonstratively
and in a measured
fashion that's what the nhs want to hear
and he's get out there amongst the nhs
they don't want
someone who's looking for headlines
every evening
and who's looking to kind of climb the
greasy pole
sludge has already done it i mean he's
held two of them are you saying that
are you talking about anybody in
particular there maybe
not me i assure you uh but that's why
you kind of all sit from the personal i
mean they've had
i mean jeremy hunt was was in many ways
a very good health secretary
in the years he did that that job i've
got my issues with him but
you know he he sort of exuded
uh confidence and and and quiet
modest a quite modest approach to
politics and i think that's what sajid
will bring as well